People email us questions and we try to answer them. Okay.
Hopeful bars with Bobby Khalilah, Michael Bruce pig. Um, Rebecca,
uh, Hey friends,
my fiance and I are about to have a baby she's only two months along,
but it seems so close to nine months. My, uh,
my problem is I can't get her to quit smoking cigarettes.
As soon as I found out she was pregnant,
I quit because I want what's best for our baby in our family.
How can I try to convince her to quit without making her think she's against
what's best for our family? I know she loves me and I know she'll love our baby,
but I know she can love herself. Me and our baby so much more.
If she does things she knows she needs to do. Thanks. Love you guys.
How does he convince his fiance to quit smoking for the baby?
And you convince how do you convince Rebecca?
I mean, it's pretty obvious. Number one, cigarettes kill you.
They'll kill the mother. They could kill the baby.
They're doing harm that's for sure. Rebecca,
this is why I push this over to you. Listen,
there's one thing she knows about it's babies,
drinking miles pregnant while pregnant, eating,
whatever kind of foods whilst pregnant. I was like, this is your wheelhouse.
All right. Let's let's let's okay, Rebecca. So I'm just going to say,
let's suppose I'm your friend where you, you and I have work.
I go to orange County. Okay. You and I have ring brunch, right?
You and I are having brunch. Right. And I'm talking collarless pregnant.
So I'm going to go to Rebecca Khalilah. You know,
she's two months pregnant as you know, I'm right next to you in front of you.
And I'm just, and you see that. Yeah. She was smoking. She was pregnant.
What would you say?
I would say.
I'm completely. Non-confrontational be like, Oh my God, when you left,
I'd be like, Oh my God.
[inaudible] constantly, when she's pregnant, that's disgusting.
And then whenever you come up, [inaudible],
I'm so bad like that. But yeah, no, she's really,
really damaging the health for unborn baby.
That baby could be born with a low birth rate. I know that much.
If you smoke heavily, whilst pregnant. Sorry, but low birth weight.
Yes. I might've said right. Low birth weight.
I just don't think that it would be, it's not the healthiest,
like taking vitamins. Vitamins would be good. Right? Vitamins are great. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, it's not as bad as heroin. If it was heroin,
I would be like, Hey man, put the needle down.
I feel like heroin is better than nicotine. You think so? Well,
no, not heroin. Cause the baby would yeah. Yeah. It'd be withdrawals. Yeah.
Yeah. Maybe crack
[inaudible]. Yeah. I just think, you know what I would do.
I would just like sit down with her and go, listen,
I don't care what you do with your body. I do. Right.
But if you choose a smoke smoke, but you have our baby inside,
you can you wait until you have the baby? Or at least be drunk.
You know what I mean? Get drunk,
drunk a cigarette can be nice, you know? Right, right, right.
You're not even drunk yet. You're sober. She's like, yeah. I'm here.
Print this risky. I would say, you know what I mean?
Like that stop being a selfish. Yeah.
That's crazy bit inside your stuff you should know better.
Is that a real question? That is a real question. That's a real question.
We get so many weird ones. Don't be a selfish. You have a baby inside you.
There we go. There we go. That's the answer. That's the answer.
Don't be a selfish. Do we have another one? Because that's a given. Yeah.
Hello. My name's Ethan. I've been single for six years. There's been dates,
but sex there's been dates and sex with zero intimacy recently started dating a
young lady and I cannot keep it up during sex long enough for me to finish.
She gets off and I'm going soft. Yeah.